TRANSPONDER AN AIR AFTER
TAKEOFF.
>> Reporter: INSIDE THE COCKPIT
OF A BOEING 777, THERE ARE
MULTIPLE WAYS THAT THE PILOTS
COMMUNICATE WITH THE GROUND.
INFORMATION BEAMS DOWN AND UNTIL
TODAY WE THOUGHT THE LAST
TRANSMISSION WAS 1:07 A.M. LOCAL
TIME.
NOW THERE IS WORD IT MAY HAVE
BEEN TRANSMITTING DATA HOURS
BEYOND THAT.
WHAT INFORMATION -- GIVE ME
DETAILS, WHAT KIND OF
INFORMATION IS BEING BEAMED
DOWN.
>> ENGINE PARAMETERS,
TEMPERATURES, AMOUNT OF FUEL
BURNED, ANY MAINTENANCE
DISCREPANCY.
>> AIRLINES MONITOR THE REALTIME
DATA.
RADIO, ALL RIGHT, GOOD NIGHT,
THE FINAL CALL FROM THE PILOTS
OF FLIGHT 370 LEFT MALAYSIAN AIR
SPACE.
A COMMON PHRASE WHEN CHANGING
CONTROLLERS.
>> ALASKA AIRLINES FLIGHT 261
WHEN THE PLANE DIVED OUT OF
CONTROL, PILOTS RADIOED WHAT WAS
HAPPENING.
BUT NO MAYDAY FROM FLIGHT 370.
>> IN THE EVENT OF AN EMERGENCY,
IS COMMUNICATION SECONDARY?
>> YES.
THE FIRST PRIORITY IS TO FLY THE
AIRCRAFT AND THEN COMMUNICATE.
>> Reporter: A THIRD WAY TO
COMMUNICATE, BY TRANSPONDER.
12:1, A.M., THE PLANE LOSES
CONTACT.
>> IS THERE ANY GOOD REASON THAT
A PILOT WOULD WANT TO SWITCH
THAT OFF?
>> NO.
CLEARLY, IF ALL OF THE POWER WAS
LOST TO THE AIRCRAFT OR
SOMETHING HAPPENED TO TAKE OUT
THAT PART OF THE ELECTRONICS,
THE ELECTRICAL SYSTEM, YEAH,
THAT WOULD TURN IT OFF.
BUT CERTAINLY ONE ASPECT OF
TURNING IT OFF IS BECAUSE YOU
DON'T WANT TO BE SEEN.
>> Reporter: RADAR TRACKED
FLIGHT 370 FLYING FOR ANOTHER
NINE MINUTES.
THEN THE PLANE VANISHES.
BUT THE ONE PIECE OF THE PLANE
THAT IS LIKELY STILL
COMMUNICATING, THE FLIGHT
RECORDERS.
ONLY SONAR EQUIPMENT CAN DETECT
THEIR PINGS AND TIME IS OF
ESSENCE.
THE SIGNAL ONLY